[Music]
with alien Covenant a feature film for
the popular alien franchise was last
released six years ago after the film
was not really well received and the
predecessor Prometheus also fell short
of expectations the time has long since
come for a reboot of the film series
this is finally going to happen at 20th
Century Studios with evil dead and don't
breathe director Fede Alvarez who
already has notable experience in the
horror genre he has been overseeing the
filming of what is officially the fifth
alien movie since March 9th one that is
not a prequel nor a crossover with a
much younger cast than before according
to an article by The Hollywood Reporter
the upcoming film with the working title
alien Romulus will focus on a group of
young people living in a distant colony
who find themselves in a fight for
survival with the eponymous alien a
total of five new cast members have been
announced with mayor of East Town
actress Kaylee spaney taking the lead
role in addition to actors Spike Fern
and Eileen Wu we will also see industry
star David Johnson Transformer the last
night star Isabella Merced and Archie
Renault best known from Shadow and bone
on screen a participation of Sigourney
Weaver as Alan Ripley seems rather
unlikely at this point 2024 seems to be
a realistic time frame for the
theatrical release of alien 5 based on
the current filming start but official
information is still missing in parallel
to the feature film an Alien series by
the showrunner of Fargo Noah Hawley is
also in the works we can therefore look
forward to more news about the franchise
[Music]